because like i said i text him back
today so listen
and we're live he says my girlfriend
says danielle says hey he's making
progress i said tell your girlfriend
you're whooping my ass every time i
leave i cry like a little baby
anyways
today we have a special guest with us
the one and only
chance palminteri aka sunny chas thank
you for joining us on the podcast good
to be here it's great to have you i was
i tweeted something out last night we
were talking about i said sometimes the
best podcasts are the ones not recorded
because last night's podcast was insane
at casa de
uh we had a good time but uh you know
everybody was asking questions i know
there's a lot of things that we want to
cover you know of course
one of the best things yesterday when i
was talking to my trainer this morning
when he told the story about both
michael jordan and magic johnson saying
their favorite movie of all time is
bronx tale yes right so
jason kidd jason kidd well we have to
put him there because he's a head coach
now right he was a decent point guard
yeah rizzo from the yankees favorite
movie wow oh i can go on and on well
keep going no just but you got to
realize the movie is i don't think
people really realize like this morning
i'm talking to the trainer
and he says uh how you feeling i said
good i said today we got a special
podcast he says who's on i said we had
dinner with
chaz last night he says chancellor
that's a chance parliamentary says
chad's chaz i said yeah chaz from uh
bronx said yeah he says one of my
favorite movies of all time i said do
you know that's his story
and he's like no yeah i said that's a
story so chaz if you don't mind maybe
share with us and the audience your
story and how it led to you writing
bronx tale
okay
all right i'll uh i'll try to condense
it
sure i can what happened was i was in la
uh i was um and i i first i was in new
york obviously i'm a new york guy i was
an actor and
and then i said you know what i'm going
to try la so i went out to la i saved
some money maybe four five grand i said
all right you know maybe it'll get me
started you know and i started like as
soon as i got there bam i got on hill
street blues bam i got on dallas bam i
got on mad luck i was like guest
starring i was like all right man what
year is this what year is this uh this
is 86. got it 86.87 this acting thing's
easy
so your late 20s early 30s
late 30s late middle 30s so i said man
this is
you know i mean i was doing okay in new
york but theater i wasn't doing much
film you know
so i said wow and then all of a sudden i
started after you do the guest star
rolls you know you start running out of
places to go back to you they can't
bring you right back
so
i started running out of money again and
i says oh man wow look at this you know
after about a year i started running out
of money and i said well i got to go
back to what i do and that was i was a
doorman bouncer that's what i did in new
york amazing you know you know so i said
all right something you and gerard have
in common yeah yeah and jerron have that
you know so i i i got into uh got a club
a real swanky club in beverly hills uh
called 2020. it was in the beverly
center i remember and i'm working there
one day and i'm working there for about
a couple of months and the guy's really
nice she's letting me go on auditions
the guy loved me and i and i was and i'm
i'm a really good doorman balancer i can
really handle myself but
i don't i always get out with my mouth
because i'm really funny and i could
talk you know also when i would mess up
your pretty face no you don't exactly i
don't want to do that
so
all of a sudden one night there's three
rules to a doorman i'm sure uh you know
my man over here gerard would know
there's three main rules about it what
are these rules here's here are the
rules you ever seen roadhouse you never
say the word
do you know who i am never because you
say that to a doorman immediately he
knows who you are you're an [ __ ]
you're saying if you're the customer
walking in yeah yeah you're a customer
yeah okay and you give him a little bit
of say could you hold on one second he
goes excuse me do you know who i am no
that is like if i have to guess who you
are then you're not really somebody
and i usually always my standard answer
was
yes you're the guy who's not getting in
tonight that's who you are oh and that
would really
so this guy got really pissed off the
second rule is you never touch the rope
never touch the rope you grab the rope
you're not getting him of course and the
third rule is you never get in the
doorman's face like close
so this guy
he comes over he goes let me and i have
again this is my party and i just looked
at him you know a little short guy bald
with these big glasses and i said to him
excuse me just relax for me hey he grabs
the rope
gets in my face and goes do you know who
i am
in three seconds he broke all three
rules in this guy okay and i said you're
the guy who's not getting in tonight
just like that and he goes you will be
fired in 15 minutes
i said really yeah get on the line
everybody says that and who is the guy
swifty lazar now for those of you who
don't know swifty lazarus swift lazar
was the biggest agent in the world no
man the biggest
represented you know
elizabeth taylor everybody the biggest
agent in the country all right pull this
gentleman up swifty lazar thrifty lazar
you see short guy ball big big glasses
and i just told him that he's not
getting into his own party get out of
here he's going to party
this is swift
what a freaking character good looking
guy he looks like junior
exactly
those glasses and chat if you watch
sopranos you would get the reference but
and sharing and [ __ ]
i get fired in 15 minutes it looks like
the six flags guys i get in my i get in
my car
i get in my 19 seven i you know i
started i was broke i had a knife so you
got fired i got fired oh yeah just 10
minutes 15 minutes gone he broke all the
rules that you got the guy came over to
me the owner he felt so bad he goes chaz
i i got to let you go man this guy has
parties three or four parties here a
year i got a mortgage
he goes but i love you man i i said hey
man you've been good to me you always
let me audition don't worry about it i
left
i get in my my junk car and i drove back
to my little dumpy apartment in north
hollywood and i said what am i going to
do
i said i'm running out of money again
i'm in my late 30s
i said well you know what i look up and
i see my father's card saddest thing in
life is wasted talent there it is that's
it right there something that i'm very
familiar with yeah and i see that card i
just happened to look at it i said
because i always brought it with me and
i said you know your father's card my fa
my father wrote on a card the saddest
thing in life is waste of time this was
your father's catchphrase
was a bus driver my father was a bus
driver so everything from the bronx de
niro's part the bus driver yes my father
lorenzo yeah wow exactly for people that
don't know chaz what's your real name my
real name is clujo
see my name is colloidal lorenzo
palminteri
my friends call me see my clothes you
know my guys that i grew up in so anyway
yeah let me explain to you what happened
so i'm sitting there so i said you know
what if they won't give me a part
because i want to do film movies it's
very difficult to get into movies i had
broadway credits they don't give a [ __ ]
over there into hollywood so i said you
know what
if they won't give me a great part
then i'll write one myself i went to
thrifty drugstore i got five tabs of
yellow paper i sat down i said what am i
gonna write i always remember this
killing that i saw when i was nine years
old i was sitting on the stoop i thought
they were fighting over a parking space
yeah
baseball bad guy was exactly the same
exactly right exactly wow and all of a
sudden i remember he killed him and then
he stared at me and i stared at him and
the next minute my father grabbed me by
my arm and dragged me up steps and i
remember that whole scene so i wrote
that just that one bit and i did it for
my theater workshop on monday
and then everybody was like wow
yeah you know so i said whoa wait a
minute this is really good so each week
i would write more and more and each
week on monday i would go back and
perform it at my theater workshop
and every time i would keep two minutes
three minutes four minutes i kept
workshopping it you know what i mean
absolutely you edited edit
i would i would tape everything with a
dis you know uh cassette player and i
would tape it and go back and right look
at it perform it for them perform it
after about a year of doing that i had
90 minutes of this show that was tight
as a drum your own proof of concept
it was done because
i i performed it i saw what worked and
what didn't work
that's the key you know you i was able
to develop it
the fact that calls it testing tuning
testing
you have to test it you have to if you
really want to be sure
so what i did was i said okay now here
we go now how do i do this i said well i
got now how do i get the money i need
money to produce it i call my friend who
i work who i was his bodyguard in new
york
not a legit guy peter gation his name
was and he owned the clubs and a legit
guy he owned the limelight in new york
anyway i told him about it he says you
know what
he says i always i saw you in a play you
got a lot of talent
he goes let me think about it i thought
he blew me off the next day i get a
knock on the door i opened the door
fedex gives me a check for like uh i
think it was 40 grand you're kidding me
yeah just like that he just sent me 40
grand
and i called him up i said you didn't
even know what i have you didn't read it
he goes no no no i saw you you got
talent he goes that's it that's it
wow i said okay i took the 40 grand i
got a little theater
i hired a little producer boo boom boom
i got a box office i put up the show
and bam
people were coming from all over
hollywood to see this people when you
got to see this it was it got so crazy
that i had to move into the a big
theater this was a one-man show before
it was a movie yes it was a one i did
all the characters
what i said was
i said i'm going to do a one-man show
i'm going to do a movie on stage like by
myself so i did it you played the little
kids c and i played
everybody is a film adaptation yes
that's insane you didn't know that no
that's crazy why not why am i here what
am i doing
with you right now he wrote the script
optioned the script i thought it was a
traditional i am
you know the story about somebody try to
somebody cut him a chick for like a
million bucks let me walk away william
so i so
what happened was people were seen as
they go my god they go this is a movie
the man is doing a movie on stage it's
brilliant oh they said all these great
things this is what your late 80s this
is 1989 okay
so then we went into this all of a
sudden i'm doing the now here i was i
was a nobody right all of a sudden uh
jerry weintraub ray stark tom pollock
all these people
al pacino jack nicholson
burt reynolds they're all coming to see
the show they want to play sonny and
these other guys want they want the
property
hollywood a-listers
extraordinary yeah wow
after i do it two weeks later
i get a phone call
from universal they said we love it we
were there forget it this is a this is
great we want to give you 250 000 for
the property and i said
i said oh wow i got no money now i got
200 bucks in a bank
i said well what what about um gotta
love it what about you know i'm gonna
play sonny right i want to write it it's
my life they said no no no we just want
the property i said well no no no i said
i have to play sonny they said well we
can't do that i said well i won't do
then they said forget the check then
i said okay they
so now i'm saying 200 bucks in your
pocket they also say no to a quarter
million quarter million
eighty nine you gotta see where this
goes next stop my hand to god i'm
telling you exactly what happened
i do it three weeks later
they call back
five hundred thousand
but no you know me no i said look i
can't do this
i'm sorry i have to play sonny i got to
do the screenplay
again they said no so i said forget it
so now icm william morris and caa are
all chasing me they want me right
and all of a sudden i said well you know
i started meeting with everybody with
all three of them yeah so
to tell you how crazy this was guys how
insane what happened was
my car had a little hole in the radiator
so the leak would it would leak so i if
i forgot to put water in it would
overheat so in the morning i'm meeting
with william mars
it was about the third or fourth meeting
it overheated and i said oh look at this
so i called him up i said hey man i
can't be there today they were what's
the matter why did you sign with
somebody else i said no no i
my car had overheated your car you have
trouble with your car go yes
sit right there we'll call you right
back just don't move
i said what so i hang up the phone i
said what was that about right
all of a sudden one hour later i'm not
going to do it i open up the door this
is this guy there he's got like a
uniform he goes you chase momentary i go
yeah he goes come with me
i go who are you he goes i have
something for you i go down in my
in my parking lot you know there's all
these beat up cars because we're all
actors living in this dump right i see a
brand new
cadillac dorado black
black with saddle interior he gives me
the keys he goes here william mars got
this for you
he goes they said thanks william don't
be late for your audition for your
meeting
i said what the [ __ ]
[Music]
so i called them up and i said i said
hey man what what what are you doing
they said no no no we don't want you to
we don't we we don't want you you
shouldn't be driving around you're gonna
get an accident but
i said but i didn't sign with you guys
yet they said that's okay we leased it
for two years for you
if you want to sign with us you sign
with us if you don't
don't forget good for them that's why
what an approach right what an approach
p.s i ended up signing yeah exactly
because i mean they just wanted me so
bad i mean what an approach right so
would you have signed with them without
the car
were you in between those three options
i was but they had such wanted me so bad
that you could you know you felt wanted
you filled with yeah yeah i mean look
caa did and and icm did too they met but
it was more of a meeting look we like
the property we this was like you got to
be here we will do you know and and
there's you know so you do it how does
that make you by the way these are the
stories you don't hear about behind
closed doors on how to sell you got to
give respect to william morris for doing
what they did that's very creative that
was created yeah very good this is why
you're always treating your top guys so
good like this but i love this stuff
yeah this is stuff you don't see this is
stuff that people tell the story 30
years later dude for people it's a
lesson for people that have never been
like in on auditions or been a
struggling actor or been talented and it
just hasn't been a right role for you it
can you could be very very talented and
just not in the right place not with the
right representation right the the the
entertainment industry is so unforgiving
man how
you're in your mid-30s your broken
radiator broke dude right how the hell
do you turn down a half million dollars
where's that willpower come from you
know what i don't know people ask me
that question and i was just so driven
i'm a very driven guy i'm very stubborn
i'm 100 sicilian
and i'm just like hey this is my shot
and people are going you sure you're 100
well i don't know i gotta i gotta do
another dna test with that
that's a good run back i had dinner last
night that's a good call back yeah that
was worth it
so you're saying you're you're stubborn
you're you're 100
yeah so what happened was now i give
away marsh and they say we're going to
set up this big meeting field we got to
be like
i meet with these with another studio
so the guy has a piece of paper like
this i'm sitting down there's 12
people around this big table my agent on
one on the left one on the right
the guy's talking to me goes chaz we all
came to see the show we know everybody
wants to do it he goes i have this piece
of paper here he goes like this
slides it over to me just like that
he says if you sign that paper you'll
have a check tomorrow for one million
dollars
and i and i said to him
patrick i looked at him and i went is
there a bathroom here and he said yeah
there's the executive bathroom right
over there i said excuse me
i just get up and i walk into the
bathroom i go into the bathroom and i'm
just walking around the bathroom
and i'm saying one million dollars i
could help my parents i could this is it
right
and all of a sudden i put my hand in my
pocket
and for some reason
that morning i took the card with me i
don't know why but the card was there
saddest thing i like his ways to tell
him
i look at it and i go
i look in the mirror and i go
[ __ ] it
and i walked back out and i sit down and
i said uh
well
i'll sign that paper and the old like
you can see they were getting really
giddy
and i said but
i play sonny and i write the screenplay
and their heads went like this
and i said well he says chaz i'm sorry
we can't do that and i said okay i stood
up and went
takes breaths and when you stand up at a
meeting it's over it's done that's right
yo you stand up the meetings all that's
right and my my agents it's like this
they're looking at me like
this cost me a hundred grand this guy's
hundred grand yeah so they got up with
me and i said i'm sorry and i'm walking
out and he goes hey guys let me tell you
something chaz you realize this movie
will never get made just like that to me
and i said
yeah it won't get made with you
and he goes what makes you so sure i
said because it's just too [ __ ] good
that's why
and he said i wish you well i said i
wish you well and i walked out
and all of a sudden two weeks later i'm
doing the show
crowds i mean everybody's i mean it was
you couldn't get a ticket for months it
was crazy i'm doing the show
and then i get off the stage and the
stage manager runs over me says chaz
robert de niro who's in your dressing
room he snuck in there after the show
he's waiting for you
i go robert de niro
i said robert de niro roberta he goes
yeah
so i walk into my dressing room and
there's bob sitting there you know he's
sitting there he's look you know he goes
uh
that's the greatest one-man show i ever
saw i said well thanks bob
he goes
you did a movie that's a movie and i
went yeah and he went
he goes let me talk to you about what i
want to do and i just looked at him and
i said okay he goes look if you end up
selling this thing they're going to come
to me anyway
he goes but
you know he had a nice approach to me
but but i wasn't going to sell it wait
wait he says if they end up selling
they're going to come to me bob anyway
they're going to give me the job yeah he
goes if you sell this thing yeah to a
studio they're going to come to me
so he goes but i'm gonna tell you
something right now he goes i know what
you want he goes i think you'll be
greatest sonny and i think you should
write this screenplay because it's your
life he's an actor he knows he knows he
goes it'll be honest and nobody will
yeah sanitize and water it down he goes
it'll be real he goes i'll direct it and
i'll play your phone no [ __ ] he goes and
we'll you know we'll be together and
nobody will touch it and he went
anyone like that anymore if you shake my
hands that's the way it'll be
i shook his hand and that's what
happened
bob deniro came in and that's how you
make it all like batman yeah exactly
that's that's how you guys i ended up
getting more than the million and played
sonny
and wrote the screenplay and not only
that you did so good in that role
unusual suspects right analyze this
my whole career was right that was my
whole career talk about betting on
yourself yeah you get you got to realize
that there's so many lessons in the
movie bronx tale like there are so it's
not like one or two or three it's
non-stop and sometimes
when when you make a movie and you try
too hard to put the message in the movie
you lose the entertainment
absolutely you got both of that you got
the story and the lessons now why did
you want to play sunny why don't you
want to play your dad
but i i knew
because sonny i knew was the flashy part
and i knew i didn't want to play my dad
i i just sonny was the character that i
loved it was because he was so
sonny was a strange guy he was really a
rough he was he was very tall like you
know he was very handsome
it was a he was a fighter i mean who was
sunny in real life come on you know i
can't answer that question people ask me
not call the time you know i mean he got
whack he had you know anyway he was a
real guy he was a real guy okay and
sonny he was basically miami don't know
the rules about that yeah you don't know
i'm sorry you're right i'm sorry
please forgive me yeah okay
so um so what did he do for a living i
mean really i mean come on so
gee was he a wise guy i mean come on
stop it
uh keep going keep going all right did
you speak it to this microphone yeah so
anyway
you know he um
uh where was i oh yeah so we did it and
it just
it just exploded man i mean
you know bronx tale is taught
in schools bronx tale is taught in
colleges there's a book called the moral
intelligence of children
by robert cole that he dedicated a whole
chapter to bronx tale on the education
of children yeah i mean it's did i know
this when i saw when i was read these
things i go
man i didn't know i was that smart you
know i didn't
all i did was write a story yeah but it
was lightning in a bottle
just like patrick's and it's lightning
at above it goes so far beyond your your
normal um you know mob genre i mean how
many guys before the before there was a
uh
uh you know your electric starter in the
car how many people wanted to see if the
girl would open the door
it's not one or two or three it's not
stopping yeah chess question who owns
the movie rights right now the movie
right
the nero does yes
i own the old theatrical rights you own
theatrical rights he owns the movie
right he owns crazy yesterday we're
having dinner together
and you tell a story about when people
typically approach your table you know
when you're at dinner they're very
respectful right and sometimes people
approach you and they're you know
they're qualified [ __ ] which means
yeah not awful very rare very sure that
happens so
you tell this story like literally he's
telling the story an hour later
guy walks up to the uh to
there's a background someone's audio is
up so lower your audio because we can't
hear it okay so guy walks up to the guy
walks up to the what do you call the
table right and he says i know you he
looks at me he says
you're my neighbor he says i'm trying to
figure out so what's that guy's name so
guess the number he says i said okay
cool i said good to meet you says you
and i have the sh i said that's right
you have the show the guy has two
beautiful cars by the way nicest guy
we're having a camera and i asked that
nice question that you appreciate it a
lot
and then i say
you obviously know i said where are you
from it says new york i said but where
are you from he says new york i said now
where's your family from i said where is
your family from he says italian i say
you know who this is of course i know
who this is.
and then what does he say he says he
read for the part of clojure he read for
the part of colombia and got through
three different auditions was doing it
for six weeks that's pretty sick and
then he says
oh yeah yeah march 16th we're coming to
the show and for a lot of the brown we
bought 16 whatever it was yeah we bought
16 tickets we never miss it when chaz
comes here and then he just went talking
about it right last night about what it
was so that that story affected a lot of
people to know that uh you know the
lessons that but one of the things i
want to ask about the lessons in there
was the following
is you're walking down with the younger
version of you and sonny is walking out
with a younger version of you
and
says so hey you know there's only three
things you do in jail what are they i
think it's uh you fight you
gamble you play i don't know what you
play
cards yeah and he says what'd you do he
says i read and he says what'd you read
you said machiavelli yeah and he says
what's machiavelli he says machiavelli
was a somebody you know right and you
give the history of it
and then he said so what'd you learn you
said availability yes and he said what
do you mean availability he said i can
live anywhere why do i live here can you
unpack the concept of availability i
mean it was brief but i'm curious to
know about them
what happened was the wise guys
especially sunny he read machiavelli in
jail but not just him wise guys have
read sure it's it's mandatory it's
mandatory right
so
and when he explained it to me i was
like
i i and i i didn't read it back i read a
little bit back then but when i started
researching it when i was writing the
thing what i did was i took the
machiavelli principle and i made it into
his street language so what i did was
where he goes availability
let's say well this is actually right
from the play
i said availability goes yeah
availability he goes i can live anywhere
i want to live why do you think i live
here he goes availability
he goes
he goes he goes you see me he goes uh
i'm trying to think how he does he was
availability he goes because the people
that's he goes up he goes a boss always
has to be available
what a freaking lie always he goes
because the people that see me here
every day that are on my side they feel
safe
they feel safe do you realize how
powerful this is and he's saying that
they feel safe because they know i love
them but the people that want to do
otherwise
they think twice
because they fear me so
you know the people that want to hurt
him that he when he's around there it's
different i mean
what i did was i took it to the next
level and i put it i put it into street
terms right and then in that scene
correct me if i'm wrong c asked back
well
is it better to be loved there's a
better fearless exactly and that's he
asked that question and this is a very
big topic on this movie right he goes is
it better to be loved or feared and he
said that's a good question he goes um
what he says to me goes he goes that's a
good question he goes
he goes in my world is better to be
feared right because trouble is like a
cancer when it's small like this it's
easy to cut out and get rid of but when
you're not around to see the trouble it
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
then it eats the whole
you know and then you say the trick is
fearless not to be hated not because
that's right then he goes the trick is
not to be hated right he goes that's why
i treat my men well right not too well i
give them too much then they become
independent from yes i give them just
enough when they need me
but they don't hate me yeah awesome i
mean it's
i gotta tell you it's powerful this is
the first movie the first movie in my
life back in the day with vhs my father
actually woke me up from sleep and said
come on you got to come see this he
dragged me out we had just moved out of
brooklyn we were in jersey and he played
the scene about you know the working man
the working man is a sucker a whole
powerful scene
but also he swears to god to this day my
father was a brooklyn marine and a
garrison beach husky and he swears to
god from this day that that scene with
the bikers yes comes from the garrison
beach what they what they let me tell
you something we hear that when i hear
that i hear that
20 times a year
this came from 189th street uh this came
from queens yeah i know that story and i
go no it didn't no
maybe your thing happened there but no
this happened here i was sitting at the
bar this happened you know so everybody
says that yeah
everybody says that
sonny in that scene that pat references
with the machiavelli scene and
everything like that
prior to that like literally the minute
before that
uh your dad robert nero dropped sonny uh
dropped c off on the bus he sees you
across the street and he sees louis
dumps across the street where's my 20
right and you say well this is your
friend do you like this guy i know he
says no he's in there yeah exactly and
he says forget the 20. yeah and i'm like
what he goes look look at it this way
cost you twenty dollars to get ready to
get rid of him out of your life he's
never gonna bother you again he's never
gonna ask you for money again he's out
of your life for 20 hours exactly he
says you got off cheap you kind of cheap
we were talking about this last night
about
having to pay for situations where you
know things could get ugly and it's like
you know in this case 20 bucks you got
off cheap maybe 50 grand you get off
cheap right you know 100 grand the store
you told you could have got off cheap
what's the money lesson at that it's
just you cut your losses basically you
cut your losses and you know what he's
nev he can't ask you for money again
ever
you got to be machiavelli on these guys
look i knew my friends i knew my friends
i was doing all this in hollywood just a
funny story i'm doing all this in
hollywood right i knew my friends were
going to ask me for money because it was
going to be in the newspapers it was
going when you got the mail when i got
the oh i got more than a million well
they all were they offering you money
when you had a broken radiator though
that's the other side of it so i called
i called my friends up before
all this hit big yeah and i went you
know you know i'm doing okay but i need
listen to me is it possible you can let
me 10 grand get out of here now i knew
they was you know what
no way they could give me 10 grand they
were married guys you know yeah they're
chad's i can't i got kids i totally
understand that don't worry about it you
know i'm just a little desperate right
now called all five of them seven of
them up wow and i asked them for money
boom as soon as i got to check they
couldn't ask me for money of course
wow
so what's that they called me up and i
said hey yeah congratulations hey yeah
it all worked out i didn't need the 10
grand thanks
that's awesome
wow i won't i won't tell you who it is
but there's the only thing i've ever
heard that even remotely comes close to
that there's a guy who played ball
he he had been divorced twice and was
about to get divorced for the third time
so he was a veteran okay
so he calls every single divorce divorce
lawyer
in the state
so that when he when he files for
divorce his wife at the time
cannot get a divorce lawyer oh because
he's already entered into conversations
so he literally took two days of his
life and called a thousand attorneys
veteran because this was his third time
i was like bro you really wanted out of
that well he's an experienced
divorce that's your third one you know
none of those guys could even they
couldn't attempt to ask you because they
already have one guy did but
you didn't give me the 10 grand i asked
you now you need to yeah i said no oh
you want money now but i assure you he
goes oh come on i could i said no i
can't do it man i couldn't afford it
chance that's awesome chess dude
i still can't get over the fact you're
in your 30s you're a struggling actor
man and you're out there you're bottom
dollar somebody wants to buy a script
they want to option your script that in
and of itself is a dream half a million
dollars no no yeah you understand that
that's like hitting on 20 right like
like you're showing two kings and you're
hitting this only happened three times
in the history of hollywood happened
three times it happened with sly sloane
rocky rocky happened with me obviously
bronx still and it happened again with
big fat greek wedding uh so it happened
three times that's it that what that
where the person wrote the one-person
show and actually was in it and it was
in the movie three times that happened
sure it happened a few more times and it
didn't end up well though no no yeah at
this level yeah
at this level yeah yeah at this level
success sure success where was it and
then you turned it into you've been in
some of the most insane ensembles in the
history of film i mean unusual how did
unusual suspects come about no they just
called me up and they said
they want to offer the role and uh i was
like really excited by that you know he
saw bronx tale he said
he'll be great as that and
and i said great you know okay and what
was your character's name it was the
police agent agent
yeah exactly yeah i know it's
interesting i was in a room with kevin i
was doing another movie
jade
was it jade yeah jade right after that
so what they did was they put me in a
room with kevin spacey for ten days and
we did the we did it all our scenes and
then i left and then they started the
movie
okay listen the final scene where you
dropped a cup of coffee oh spoiler okay
i'm not going to say no no
if you haven't seen people suspect at
and everything that's going on i was in
a barbershop quartet in the music and
verbal kent is walking and he's doing
his thing
top five scene of all time yeah i mean
seriously they say it's one of the times
i watch that and you get the all the you
ever heard i get all the feels right
yeah it gives you all right
by the way this this is the great thing
i like when i see movies like that i
like to bring friends over who i've
never seen because i just want to watch
their reaction
because i remember my reaction the first
time when i saw that scene i watched
that scene this morning just to rem i i
get like sick teared up still benicio
del toro kevin spacey
but if you guys have not seen usual
suspensions you got to watch the whole
thing that's a great movie kaiser shows
it and the final scene is so ridiculous
that's a great script look at what the
whole academy award yeah you know the
director brian singer was brilliant the
music was brilliant you know the actors
it was one of those things everything
just came together man kevin pollock
kevin pollock people don't know that
he's actually a funny guy he's
communicating right now oh very funny
yeah hilarious right that's what we're
talking about exactly what's his name
kevin kevin paul
let me ask you because great line in
entourage is it's not the movies you do
that bomb that kill you it's the movies
that you pass up on and i i'm a big will
smith fan and he was telling a story
you're huge on tick tock you're getting
massive on tick tock i know will smith
was telling a story about how he turned
down the role of neo for people that
don't know in the matrix the matrix is
rebooting it's coming back out really
the role of neo was written for will
smith and the wachowski brothers at the
time they pitched in this movie about
and he was like so wait i'm like ninja
jesus i don't i don't get it like this
doesn't make any sense and he's like and
it came down to he wanted to do a song
for the movie right you know like it's
not really that kind of movie saying the
wild west so he literally turned down
the matrix to do
the wild oh wow he thought the wild wild
west he he thought nature's gonna be too
esoteric nobody was gonna get it the
wild wild west is gonna be a franchise
i'm gonna do five movies i'm gonna get
albums so he he sits there and he's and
he's telling this story and it's he's
sitting there and he's like
man that was dumb like ah god yeah
sometimes you you miss
i was gonna want have you ever been
offered a role that went on to become a
banger and you were like
well one role i was offered and i don't
feel bad about it because the right guy
did it
uh and i couldn't have done it at the
time at that time i couldn't have done
it i got all for tony soprano uh in the
sopranos whoa
and i don't feel no i don't in fact i i
mean this sincerely i don't feel bad
about it at all because james
who i knew was so brilliant and so
wonderful and such a good person and i
couldn't have done it at that time i
couldn't have done it
you know so
i i just couldn't do it at the time but
i i read it and i did love the pilot but
i just couldn't do it so i
i couldn't do it so maybe i shouldn't
say i i turned it down i did get offered
it and the second one that i it still
bugs me
till this day it bugs me because i love
the movie so much and that was donnie
brasco and that was the role of uh sunny
black pacino sunny black story or joker
stone and uh
was great he killed that thing he killed
it but i i was offended first at the
time yeah uh but he killed it and i was
directing something at the time and i
but i could have worked it out if i just
would have did it but ah nah i don't
want to do it and it's one of my
favorite movies of all time wow it's one
of your favorites one of my favorite
movies and i think it's one of al's
greatest performances
yeah yeah johnny depp and i'm so upset
that i turned it down because i love the
movie so much it's such a brilliant
movie i think you would have been
monstrous in that role so when you see
these roles that these guys absolutely
kill michael matson and then james
gandolfini
do you feel happy for them is that like
okay my career has been great man of
course
yeah
i mean iconic in that role as well
sometimes it just works out you know
sometimes the right person ends up doing
it yeah and he they were the right
people so that's fine you know be
grateful man
you know life has been good for me life
is a matter with you
seriously just smack me in the head
right now
i'm playing with house money man i mean
come on how do you find the
that gratitude right there when
i guess like how gerardo said you're in
your late 30s you got 200 bucks in your
pocket do you think you would still be
as grateful like we talked about last
night health is wealth health as well
let's say this the bronx tale was never
made let's say you were never this
big time a-list hollywood actor and you
just were this right you know one-man
show guide thing got going on you never
i can't think of that because i knew
that would not happen
you had that much conviction he's a
taurus what are you talking about he's
not gonna yeah i know listen i'm thir i
was 38 years old right i got i turned
down a million dollars with 200 in the
bank
that's insane right i was insane i was i
said look
i'm doing this yeah and that's it what
is that that emotion that says i don't
give a [ __ ] about the million right i'm
doing this what is that people ask me
they say how hot i said you know what
the hardest waffle was to turn down was
the 250 i bet the first one the first
one you had the 200 bucks the no the 250
thousand yeah you had 200 bucks when you
were out
yeah but that was the hardest one
because that came out of nowhere and i
was like whoa yeah this is actually what
i can think of you are like oh my god
right but after 250 once you turn down
250 it became just numbers to me it
didn't mean anything when did you know
you belong in that world like when
you're when you're sitting there and and
uh uh bob is uh uh uh de niro's talking
to you when did you know like listen i'm
i'm i can compete in this world from day
one man from day one what gave you that
confidence my mother and father okay got
it i'm gonna tell you my mother father
who always told me you're going to be a
star and my mother my father looked the
saddest thing in life is
of course that's my my two sisters very
successful
one lives right in boca raton beautiful
big
place very successful my sister and my
other sister too both of them because
they need their confidence this is my
mother and father when i was broke and
living in new york working in place
right
my parents lived on top and i lived in
the apartment underneath when i was with
them so i would write on a card i'm in
my 20s now right dear dad
could you lend me 20
for gas and i would put the card the
index card under his door so
i didn't wake them up because when i got
back from bouncing and stuff next day i
would wake up and see the card you know
and the 20 bucks you know not the car i
mean the 20 dollars in an envelope and i
said thanks dad you know like right and
this went on for like a while six months
whatever and then i got another part and
then that was it i never hadn't needed
the money anymore
cut two
25 years later
or whatever 20 years later whatever it
is
um i'm getting i get nominated for
academy award
and i told my parents you have to come
in the car with me
and you know
uh going down the red carpet my wife is
with me i said you have to come to mom
dad and we're in the car we're just
about to we're pulling up and my father
turns to my mother and says should we
give it to him and my mother goes yeah i
give it to him now my father puts his
hand in his pocket takes out this
envelope and hands it to me goes here
you remember these
i open up the envelope
and i see all these index cards twenty
dollars twenty dollars twenty dollars
and i'm going
what's this he goes those are the cars
when you had no money you should put
them under the door and we used to give
you twenty dollars he goes we saved
those cars because we knew this day was
going to happen wow
wow by the way you owe me 380 dollars
wow that's incredible chaz can you talk
about the meaning behind like your dad
had this on his card i think i told you
the story i used to wake up every week
yeah and after seeing the movie right i
was in my 20s i was trying to figure out
life i didn't know what i was doing i
would write yeah the saddest thing is in
life is wasted talent yeah just
where did that come from i'll tell you
exactly where it came from my father
uh there was a great fighter in the 60s
he fought gaspar ortega i grew up in my
father was a bus ride but he was a
trainer too that's how i learned to
fight box and stuff and my son is a
great fighter too but anyway
my father found billy bello it was a
fighter in the 60s billy bellow and he
fought gaspar ortega and two weeks later
my father found him on the roof with a
needle in his arm jesus and
he was
devastated if you probably you could
probably go get billy on google billy
bello okay billy bello
did was he in the bob dylan song with
the hurricane no no two l's two l's
billy bello yeah billy bello and that's
where the phrase comes from
and there he is that's billy oh i got
the chills when i see that that's billy
good-looking young kids good-looking and
man the father found him yeah with him
with a needle in his arm with a needle
in his arm he died um at an overdose i
mean geez 18 years old and my father
looked at me and said
look with billy look at the talent he
had chats
and he said santa's thing in life is
wasted talent that's where it came from
he goes he goes don't ever forget that
and then he wrote it on a card
and he put it in my room that seems like
a very very philosophical guy what's
your dad's birthday when is your dad's
birthday september september 1. was it
just september 12th i think okay got it
you were saying your dad seems
philosophical he seems from from just
our
few conversations very analytical about
the world around him you know he's able
to you know he's a working man he's a
blue collar guy yeah but he was very
keenly aware of his surroundings and was
able to interpret
his surroundings in a way that that you
know could provide lessons for his son
it broke his heart it broke his heart
and he was such a great fighter and
that's where that phrase comes from did
that do you think that analytical mind
did that help you in your roles like to
get into character to be able to because
i you know i would imagine you play you
play the everyman so well yeah but it's
been a long time since you've been in
every man right so i mean
but i always feel like an every man you
know i am i don't take you know i take
my craft seriously but i don't take the
fame seriously we were very gracious
last night at dinner taking pictures
yeah the people love you they love this
they love your movies
look if you what does it take it takes
me
30 seconds to take a photo and they
remember it their whole lives
that's awesome i always have a card i
walk around with a card the saddest
thing in life is wasted talent and when
i meet an actor or somebody and they go
chance can i talk to you a second i said
yeah yeah yeah on the street they go
i go i only got a few minutes he goes
that's all right he goes could you just
give me some advice and i give them
advice and the guy i said you really
want to do this she goes yeah i open up
my wallet i take out a car and go here
here's a card
remember this card take it with you
don't waste your time and i've been
doing this for like 25 30 years right
every once in a while i meet a guy come
over to me hey chaz i want you hey man
hey i got a car let's see this car i go
yeah he goes you gave me this eight
years ago he goes i'm on a soap now i'm
doing oh i'm doing this right and i go
it's great cool man that's cool that's
sick that's awesome the impact on others
likes the impact on others let's talk
about the mob so so uh
the when we started talking and uh you
know michael francis and you you had
been on this show before i think that
was something that i've been done before
and i called you we started talking
together
and told you about the project what
turned you on to want to participate in
mafia states of america
what i really felt was when when you
when i heard about it i said wow i
thought about i said has there ever been
two maid guy two really bosses
sit down and have a sit down
where people could see it
and i thought about i said no never
i said this would be really interesting
and then i saw sammy's podcast and i saw
michael's and obviously yours
and i said wow i said this could be
really something if if this could really
work you know if it's real
if it's real if it's honest
that's then i said i would want to if
it's going to be like you know you're
going to have enactments of things ah
i don't want that i want to be involved
in that but if it's really real and raw
which mafia states is
when michael and sammy sit down with
patrick
i said okay i like to be involved in
that you know and then i met gerard
obviously the director
and uh i said okay you know this could
be good
you know i i go by my gun if something
looks and feels right
hey you know take a chance let's see
what happens yeah and you even you wrote
a lot for this as well you you
contribute on the writing side yeah i i
like to because i like to if i'm going
to be in it i i always ask would you
mind if i write and draw it was very
gracious
you know but but that that's what a good
director does they
you know they if they see something in
someone there as a director you
galvanize people you encourage people to
make the project better let me ask you
in real life was sunny a good man
meaning when you're you're robert
kiyosaki writes a book rich dad poor
that right he says my dad was uh poor
but i met this one guy that played the
role of my dad and he was a rich dad and
my dad followed all the rules got the
degree got a regular job but this rich
dad was a business guy investor real
estate all these other things and i
followed my rich dad not my poor dad
right right
when you look at the life between sunny
and your pops
was sunny
good for society was sunny a good man
was he doing the right thing sunny you
know that's what makes a bronx tale so
different and so why people want to see
it sonny was telling me exactly the same
things as my father
you have to realize that
this is not good fellows goodfellas is
brilliant a movie as it is they wanted
the kid to be a bad guy sonny was saying
don't be don't be like me
do something with your life
make you if you got talent do something
yeah now i i thought about this as i got
older i could be totally off but i
always thought that i was sonny's
penance
when in other words he was saying to
himself if i'm going to do one thing
that's right in this freaking world yeah
i'm going to make sure this kid don't go
under interesting you know now that's my
way i've seen it just to be clear are
you talking about the character are you
talking about real life oh real life
real life
yeah well he says in the movie all your
friends you're hanging out with they're
half of them are going to have
jail
that's the what that is my actual
favorite scene in the movie where he
grabs them out of the way he grabs them
out of the car that's the
if you're a tough guy he goes you think
having a gun makes you a tough guy yeah
he goes it's when the other guy has a
gun now we see what a real tough guy is
and you go oh wow he's right about time
yeah you know what i mean and but the
thing about sonny was
he wasn't black or white he was gray and
my father was great
so it was these two forces interesting
great versus great gray versus gray not
black versus white yeah it wasn't evil
and good they were both they both had
great qualities
but
the bottom line is sonny was a killer
sonny would kill you you know but he was
a great guy and he was funny
people are not just so that's why robert
cole in the moral intelligence of
children talks why children go but
why children study a bronx tale because
they go well but wait a minute but sonny
wanted him to do well
and what robert cole was saying in his
book
he goes sometimes e good and evil is not
so easily recognized it's not so
delineated you have to look at it and
study what's behind it and that's what
makes bronze tale so different chaz
what's great about your dad though what
was great about your pops my dad which
which was incredible was i couldn't tell
my dad even though
he was on a bus he he loved he worked
with
with black people and he was kind to
them and wonderful and they loved him
because he would always talk to them and
they always helped him
he didn't want i knew he wouldn't but it
would bother him if i dated a black girl
i knew it was
i knew it would
and i think the reason why
it was a product of the times 1968 it
was insane in 1916 race riots race riots
rock kennedy got assassinated
mother king
i think when i got older i asked him
that question when i got older i said
dad you know i did date a black girl i
said why he goes i know you and tell me
he goes i figured you were and i and i
said why were you upset about that why
you don't like that he goes i was afraid
for you
because of my love for you that i didn't
want you to go through that had nothing
to do with her
but in a way it did he says i just as a
son you don't want your child to go
through what he's about to face
so i understood that where sonny was
different he was like hey black white
what's the difference go ahead
interesting morality yeah morality so so
with with you being do we have the clip
with rudy or no the the clip uh do you
have that when he talks about the
italian family or no
uh uh
kai you're looking at me like a doctor
like you're confused yes no maybe you do
have it or you don't have it
yeah kyle i'm just happy with this
glasses no joke you look like a
professor at harvard maybe wharton
business school
oh what
you going for what carl from accounting
is that what it is you got the look it's
it works it works for you pat that gray
area thing that's very interesting is
that what attracts you to the mod for
your genre i i think business is great i
think business is great i think
leadership is great i think parenting is
great i think
i think it's very hard for a
black and white person to make it in
business i think it's very hard for a
black and white person
to make it in many different industries
because here's a challenge like you know
how he talks about the whole twenty
dollars uh the bronx talent and you say
the hundred thousand dollars with me
it's not the hundred thousand dollars
it's the fact that your mind is consumed
with the thought of that guy that has
your money yeah that sucks your energy
out right so the great part
if somebody's in the grade they
understand it they're like part of the
game i got to move on the black and
white part is you have to go get that
money back
you know because you're so stuck on the
principle of the fact versus the grace
like let it go you need that energy put
it here to make 10 million rather than
trying to consume so much time so no i
think on the business side by the way
you learn great the hard way you don't
learn it the right the the the the
easy way it comes with experience that's
not something that you can read about
were you black and white at one point
and then you had to like that's a black
and white guy my dad raised me
uh uh you
you met my dad my dad is very you know
strong personality that he has but he's
got a sweet side sweetest guy yeah but
but let me tell you my that's a high
standard guy it's like
you know you you say one time to him
you're gonna do something i swear to god
if you don't do it he's gonna call you a
hundred times about it but i had to
learn on the business side you
it's very complicated this whole
machiavelli thing that you you talk
about you know there's a lot of that
that applies to business this is why
books like 33 strategies award art of
seduction by robert greene you got 48
laws of power you got these these things
apply to business but going back to with
the mafia going back with the mafia
chaz
is uh
for you
you know uh uh what do you think about
the mob you know what are your feelings
about the mob there's different uh
people i'll we'll go to rudy here in a
minute i just want to know what he
thinks what do you think about the mop
at this point of your life you've been
around it yeah you get a lot of uh
sometimes people
i mean you've read it you've seen it
you've you this is you it's your life
people claimed you were part of it like
maybe there was some affinity to it a
connection to it but what are your
thoughts when you think about the mob
well the mob is not what it once was
that's for sure it's kind of like all
fractured
you know it's not what it once was and
what was it i mean
could you say it one time it was
there was real on them yeah probably
maybe the old timers there was but
what's what's the benefit of
of shaking down your own neighborhood
and people have to pay you money i don't
i don't know you know
it comes down to what my dad said
real respect real
real people who are real men
go out and they get a job and they work
for a living take care of their family
that's a real man he goes he said it
doesn't take much strength to pull a
trigger but get up in the morning every
day
so
i see them i
do i admire them now i have do i i still
see them and now i have fun with them
when i see them i laugh i talk
but i i
i respect my dad you know i respect the
guy who gets out and and make and works
and works hard a working man is not a
sucker the working man is not a sucker
no he's not
he's not look everybody in the wise guys
that i knew ended up dead or in jail
so if somebody told you if you walk out
that door every time you walk out that
door you're going to get hit in the head
with a bag of garbage you stop walking
out that door but these guys keep
walking out that door yeah
they
because that life kind of doesn't exist
anymore these were kind of like the
modern pirates this is the wild west
this is jesse james it's romantic
looking back at it and saying wow these
guys took life by the horns they did
whatever they wanted to do and nobody
could say anything right but if you
lived with them if you lived with that
type of person it had to be a hard life
to deal with that well the movie is just
romantic they have terrible lives they
have terrible lives their kids are
always forgetted
if they're not there with their children
their kids end up bad i mean i'll tell
you i'll tell you a story about a a big
wise guy in my neighborhood well he i i
don't want to mention his name
but his son
his son became a wise guy he wasn't made
of his son yet he ended up getting made
uh no i'm sorry he never got mad he was
so crazy and i'm sitting there
i'm standing there with a priest my best
friend
and this guy this wise guy on the corner
his son is walking up the block his son
was maybe 20.
okay the son is going now i could curse
right i mean of course yeah and his
son's walking up like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that and he's going to i don't give it
he's talking to another guy [ __ ] that
and i and anyway it's like there's a
priest right there he walks he was like
hey dad what the [ __ ] and his father
goes what's the matter what the hell is
wrong with you
he goes the [ __ ] guy just
he pulled this [ __ ] with me in the scam
he goes i swear to god down i'm going to
shoot him i'm going to kill him i'm
going to kill him and his father
standing right there goes quote the hell
is the matter with you
you're saying things like that in front
of people so i'm saying to myself oh
he's going to
you know reprimand his son right you
don't ever say things like that what's
wrong with you because if you're going
to whack somebody you don't stay in
front of anybody
which is good advice
this is a father
talking and i was like
did he just say that i was like
there was a priest there and we both
looked at each other like
did he just say that if you're going to
whack somebody you keep your mouth shut
i'll talk i'll be with you guys in one
minute and walks away with this kid
now
what shot does this kid got
what happened to him well i got value at
20 years old 20 years old what happened
to this kid yeah killed three people
life life in prison he ended up killing
three people killed two guys and then he
killed a guy in jail he's gone geez what
you could you expect different how he
grew up
right you're expecting the father to be
like you don't do that what's wrong with
you what's wrong if you're gonna do that
you don't tell nobody you keep it alone
what and i was crazy i was like wow do
you see anybody did you see anybody that
was able to have a normal life or no
yeah my friends no no on the mob side
made man mob side you know no okay no
ever no
the number runners some of the number
runners the i knew them
the past the father to the seventh to
the son yeah they had just normal lives
but they were just number ones yeah look
sal romano was here yesterday he said
something he says you know
you know why everybody eventually flips
and they go cooperate i said what he
says if the mob did one thing nobody
would ever cooperate i'm like what is
that he says if they
he says we're not afraid of going to
jail we're not afraid of going away we
already understand that that's part of
it every one of us has done a little bit
of time i'm like let me see what this
guy's going to be saying he says if the
mob had a program to take care of the
wives and kids when you went away nobody
would cooperate that's [ __ ] yeah
that's what he i'm just telling you what
he's saying [ __ ] okay
that is [ __ ] tell me why because
it's [ __ ] because they're just
trying to justify why they can't wait to
get they all sing this as soon as they
get caught they have run they raced to
the d.a who's gonna make the deal first
it's [ __ ] listen my my friend
you saw rudy giuliani one of my closest
friends worked for him and rudy knows
him very well
and i'll tell you who he is name is phil
foley he passed away my closest friend
would covert when covert happened it
still breaks my heart anyway
phil told me with these wise guys
because he he worked for rudy put him
all away he just one wise guy goes into
his office right he's sitting down at
the chair of course phil is going to
speak to him about you know flipping
so he goes listen now you want to make a
deal with me and blah blah blah
i don't think phil told me he's a story
he goes the guy just sits back and goes
well you know phil
i don't know what i want to do i got to
think about my future those were the
words he said
my friend phil gets up
right there's two detectives in the room
with him he says come here come here
picks the guy up grabs him by his arm
come here come over to the window brings
him over to the window and says look you
see that sun over there you see the sun
right he goes the next time you see that
sun is going to be the year 2040
2040 that's when you're going to see it
because i'm going to put you to [ __ ]
away for 40 to 50 years now get the [ __ ]
out of my office
they brought him out of the office 10
minutes later he came back he goes i'm
sorry i will make it they made a deal
come on stop it when somebody's telling
you you're going to sit in a box
for 40 years 50 years you talk it's got
nothing to do he's full of [ __ ]
uh there's so that's that's
i
i mean obviously that's why i wanted to
ask you but there's some people that
uh look at rudy and they say rudy as an
italian how the hell you put so many
people away as an italian you put away
your own people yeah and it went to jail
you you did this with the rico law all
this stuff that you go through
what do you think about rudy with what
he did in the 80s to the mob i think
rudy was great
yeah i mean look i mean i gotta be
honest with you when he came to my
neighborhood they booed him
they you know they didn't like him yeah
it was you know
because
you know but was is rudy a good man yeah
yeah he put people away these guys are
bad guys yes
you know don't get me wrong i hung out
with them but i didn't become a wise guy
i don't want to be a wise guy they're
bad guys they're the first ones to tell
you that
you know
you know are there some stand-up guys
who don't rat yeah benny eggs the old
timers guys like that francies yeah they
didn't rat you know that's it they don't
rat and okay but that's a if you want to
go that listen john gotti didn't rat
say what you want about john gotti he
was a gangster to the end
to the end
you know i'm not i'm not saying but but
at least
he stood by his code and said no this is
it
this is it a guy told me a great story i
won't tell you who he was
but when when god he was on his um on
his on his deathbed
when he was dying from throat cancer
a priest walked in
and the person whispered
to john
you know there's a a priest here
do you want the priest to and and john
went like this
right to the end man no everybody made
his decision
he already made his decision no no he
didn't want to even any final words no i
don't know if it's i don't know how do
you interpret it
i don't i don't need a preacher i made
my decision but do you think he's saying
i don't need a priest or do you think
he's saying
there's no way i'm going to have a spot
in heaven like there's no way i don't
get it how do you think you process that
i don't think he was even thinking that
yeah got it i don't think at that moment
i can't like is it like i can't i don't
know
i never met him but i think a wise guy
was just saying like nah you know i
don't want to deal with it it looks like
i'm i'm giving up at the end
not to give the audience too much here
but there's a gentleman in
mafia states of america that may
disagree with with this sentiment no no
question about it i mean obviously
there's a part of it that uh
you know
some on the other side who
from sami's camp may say in the
recording
john did kind of throw sammy under the
bus saying he was going to have somebody
take him out so there was that
i don't know about that again those
things i don't know about yeah all i
know is the guy didn't rat you know you
know what be a great sit down you know
it'll be a great sit down yeah you know
would be a great sit down
uh junior and sammy would be great sit
down yeah that would be cool i don't
know about it we wouldn't need to have a
fence we would need to have uh that
would be but that would be a great sit
down i think that one john gotti
john
oh yeah because because let both of them
hash it out in front of the world
and talk to one another now the
likelihood of that happening that's
that's right but you're not going to get
it look you're not going to get an
answer you're not going to get a
truthful answer but what would happen is
you know what would happen is is uh
i'm a big fan of a good debate yeah you
know what does a good debate do we don't
necessarily end up getting an answer but
we get a little closer to the truth
right a good debate because you watch
body language you see one person backing
down you see one person gets nervous you
see one person really gets annoyed when
you poke him in an area that's like
listen you don't poke you can poke me
anywhere this one everyone after this
person we learn a lot so i don't know
i'm not telling you it's going to happen
the likelihood is
but i'm just saying that that would be
something i i don't know uh i don't know
if that could happen i don't think
neither junior nor sammy would agree to
do that sit down i don't think they
would i think there's too much water
under the bridge i think so i think they
couldn't even talk about certain things
yeah now if it did happen how crazy
would that be if it did happen if it did
happen we would we would probably need
to get uh you know national guard there
we would probably need to get the
military there we probably need to call
yeah security yeah i just don't think it
could happen yeah now the setting too is
very very important right like you were
talking about you know rudy and who who
talked who didn't talk right the new
york you grew up in is so different from
the new york people know today
especially in the bronx yeah the bronx
was burning back in the day i mean you
were 60s and 70s in the bronx there was
a five alarm fire every day they were
trying to burn the tenants out so you
know then in the the late 70s late 70s
with son of sam right i mean like the
new york you grew up in
a lot of times i hear the stories it
feels like it was a little bit of a war
zone man
it was crazy time but i have to say i
didn't have i had a great childhood i
had a wonderful childhood so people
always go my god the child i go no no it
was great you know the wise guys ran the
neighborhood we were all tying our kids
growing up well everybody was italian in
the name but it was great so i can't say
i didn't have to me it didn't look like
like bad you know race riots the bomb no
burning there's no race riots in my
neighborhood there was nothing there was
everybody was italian there
but it was our turf you know like bronze
tail we own that and then uh the black
zone from where webster avenue was
the puerto rican zone in a different
area so you stayed in our area reggie
jackson thurman munson i mean come on
chris yeah yesterday chas is at the
house and tikko and dylan are like hi
how are you i said do you know who he is
no i say he's a very very famous actor
really what movie were you in
just like having a conversation and i
say bronx tell i said do you think it's
time for them to watch bronx still chad
says how's your son i said tico's nine
years old he says you know that's how
that was when i saw a guy get shot right
in front of me i said they're probably
ready to watch bronx sale
i know when will you let the kids watch
this listen we've already watched movies
they shouldn't watch so we'll probably
be ready
you know what and i never noticed that
about that until i had a son and then
when my son became nine
i turned to my wife i never forgot and i
said i said janna you know
dante and dante my son grew up in
bedford you know
uh you know so i look at him and i go he
was i was that age yeah and it was like
weird to me great childhood when i see a
child who's a child who's nine or ten
years old i look and i go how could i be
at that age seeing what i said crazy
right it was crazy crazy can i ask more
of a lighthearted question here yeah we
were talking about it last women again
are you gonna we're gonna go to women
we're gonna go to women okay how'd you
know
so well you talked about you know the
girl the blacker let's stay here that's
before we go because that's like a
complete right again on the 95 freeway
let's stay on a1a4 stay there kai can
you pull up the video about giuliani
before we take the street for uh because
adam's trying to learn about one i have
a question you want to learn about them
go to my podcast charles palmitari show
there it is i talk about the women all
the time
by the way kai put the link to his
podcast in the comment section as well
as the description folks go subscribe to
chaz's podcast uh you do this how often
you do show how often i do a new show
each week each week a new show okay
fantastic so
rudy says some things here about this is
when he talks about uh it's part of the
italian uh it's just part of the italian
immigrant status it's part of the
dealing with this was just part of being
from an immigrant family and being an
italian new york play play it and i want
to hear chad's thoughts on nearly as
serious as
he thought it was
i mean it's the kind of thing you could
easily explain as had nothing to do with
matilda
had nothing to do with mario
and it's the kind of thing that happened
back in those days when
you had to conduct a business and if you
didn't play ball with them
you were gonna
they were victims they weren't
they he easily could have been
interpreted that way that's the way i
interpreted it
uh but he he
he saw shadows about it you know how
sometimes people are more embarrassed
about something than they should be i
always thought that was the case with
mario largely because he was very
ethical and a very good man mario what's
this about is this about
italian heritage or no yeah this was
he's talking he's talking about mario
cuomo taking it too seriously outdated
yeah that whole thing about
you know there's uh two americas one for
the rich one for the poor i think well i
think that ended during the depression
and
uh
i didn't think if he ran he would get
elected
i thought he could be nominated but i
thought his message was too
outdated and i don't think he could have
beaten ronald reagan who was
mario was a very brilliant man he was
not a particularly great candidate his
speeches were a little late designed for
um
can i look for what part we're looking
for this was not it what i'm looking for
is when he talks about early on
um chas has a great uh a great you have
a absolutely fantastic monologue too
about the uh we can pull that up as well
but if you gave it um
really as an improv during during our
recording process
about how you know
just to be very clear not every italian
is in the mob no and italians do not
have a monopoly on organized crime
absolutely not yeah
um kai if you have that one we can pull
that one up real quick i mean i thought
that that was a brilliant brilliant
statement that that you had made as far
as what the real backbone of the italian
american community italians aren't in
the mafia
it's important to remember italians
don't have a monopoly on organized crime
and that the true fabric of an italian
neighborhood is the working man
the baker the bus driver the cop the
seamstress
you may have heard this once before but
it doesn't take much strength to pull
the trigger
but get up in the morning and work for a
living
in my opinion
that's the real tough guy and remember
the choices you make will shape your
life forever for valuetainment media
i'm chas palmitary
yeah i thought that that was like a
really really powerful when you were
growing up when you were you know you
had not even thought about
doing a bronx tale you're just living
this life
did you feel a pull towards like then
like you guys were talking about gray
yeah but did you feel like it could have
gone either way for you do you feel like
it could have i don't know if it was
that close i mean i admire them but
you see back then it was different bad
guys and good guys would all hang out
together we would all hang out on the
corner you know we had no club right you
know we were all we were straight guys
we all hang on the corner and it was
very easy to go we're gonna go do this
we're gonna go do that so the good guys
would hang and the bad guys would go do
what they got to do
you know so and every time it was like
any chance you want to come and
i would i'd be about to then i go nah
nah i'm cool man because i never wanted
to hurt my mother and father were you
ever tempted to join the life or no
i never got that close to joining the
life no i i can't even say that she got
an invitation was it kind of like hey
chaz you know you'd be great in the life
no i know it was never that i know it
was more like you get involved in a
small way you start doing the car they
were chopping up cars
you want to go there then you get you
chop up cars then he'd meet somebody
else and he meet a bigger boss and
that's how it happens i never i just
never went there i just didn't want to
do it if your if your father had
different values to teach you could that
have happened
oh yeah so so let me ask you this
question because for me i'm always
trying to find a motive
and what caused somebody to go into that
life when you hear the story about some
of these guys with their fathers
it's like automatic okay this makes
sense this person is going to be it so
how much of it you think is the
individual that wants to be part of the
life how much you think it's the
influence of the parents oh the parents
oh you put it on the parents i'm saying
the parents definitely just you got it
because when you're young what is a
parent a parent is a mirror
kids watch the way you treat your wife
they watch what you do they watch you
get up in the morning and go to work
yeah if they see that they go oh that's
how she's supposed to be they grow up
and they mirror you you know if you
treat your wife bad they'll grow up
they'll treat their wife bad it's very
simple
so you really have to as a father you
got to watch them you got to you got to
my father led by example my mother led
by example and they loved me so much i
love my sisters i didn't want to hurt
them
my father said don't ever let me have to
come to jail to bail you out please
don't ever do that to me and that would
kill me and i said i'll die don't worry
about it i would i wouldn't do that that
you know and i didn't
you know sometimes when your parents are
do not set a good example if you have a
good moral compass you might say i'm
never going to be like my father i'm
never going to do that i'm going to do
the exact opposite i've seen
billy's father and that's the man that i
want to emulate and some people go down
a different road that's hard show me
show me people who could do that that
was me yeah i did not have a good
relation to my father he was doing some
things i didn't agree with i said i'm
never going to be like you some people
can do also that yeah it's harder it's
harder it's harder but it is impossible
it is possible just because you know but
it shows it shows the it shows the value
of uh but but there is a part that
affected you though i mean if you think
about it
there's certain things in life that
probably how hard is it for you to find
somebody right now that you want to make
your wife how hard is it for yeah
because it's you're overthinking it like
what if it doesn't work what if it's
this what if it's that because there's a
part of that fear like i don't want to
ever get married to me it's like i'm
never going to get married because [ __ ]
i saw my parents get two divorces in 20
years i don't even want to deal with
this marriage stuff but i really wanted
to have kids and i wanted to have a
family i wanted to have that legacy type
of thing right so
it just tells you the power of parenting
man
it tells you the power of parenting had
a friend of mine his dad would always
slap him in the face in front of us and
the kids would and this was a grown kid
yeah that would slap him in the face man
i would walk away i'm like dude i can't
be in your house man i can't come to
your house he said i can't watch you
that slap your face it makes me feel
uncomfortable i'm not cool with that
it's very very awkward to see that take
place and what happened with that guy
he's no longer with us man i just no
literally he's no longer with us so i
think the value of parenting man that's
the part where yes
you hear kids being raised without a
father or without a a mom and dad in a
picture it's got a big uh it's got a big
influence on that look look at crime
most of these kids in jail
they're 80 percent of them have no
father that's right
where are the fathers you know when you
get these kids eight nine ten years old
it's too late
you got to get them at that you got to
get them early
i go to prisons i go to juvenile prisons
and i talk to some of the kids
okay
these kids are 14 years old they're like
men
they're like men yeah they're talking
about whacking people double murders
come on where where were the parents
where were the parents where his mother
was a junkie his father was a in
in the can yeah i mean what shot does he
have yeah what shot does this kid have
no shot nothing
it's the p you must get these kids early
purpose and accountability what are you
doing to father what do we do because
look we we're a nation of choices right
freedom of choice you get to choose to
use a condom or not nobody can force you
to say wait wait wait wait put it on
like we're not there to be able to catch
a situation right right so there's a lot
of uh temptation when you're having sex
you know you're not thinking about it
you get pregnant baby comes father bales
dude i don't want to be a father i just
wanted to have some good sex right i'm
not i'm not here to help you i don't
even have any money i can't do anything
that can't be in the picture what do you
do in those cases where the father's not
there how does the community how does
the
state how does the country address that
i don't know yeah so that's a you know
it was funny i i was um many years ago i
was at spielberg's house and i was
talking to him about a project i never
forgot that
and
a little boy came out a little boy came
out
uh black he was black very
beautiful
haircut and he had he was only about 10
years old maybe i think at the time he
had this like ralph lauren shirt pants i
mean really
stylish
and he said
and and he said chance this is my son
spielberg's son yes and i said oh he has
another son max that he has much
and again i'm not talking i don't i
don't know stephen but i'm just telling
you the story
and he said this is my son and i went oh
very nice to meet you it was very hello
really you know
and then i i said wow and and i found
out that he
adopted him
that his parents i don't know
maybe they i i don't know if they
something somebody said they were crack
addicts i don't remember exactly but now
here's this young boy think of this
that if stephen doesn't adopt him
where is he
and now he went from there
to being one of the most influential
richest people in the world right
how's his career going to be it's
you know stephen's introducing him to
life and
it's it's the parents mean everything in
a young child's life everything
people don't get it
but you got to get them early you got to
get them early chance last night when we
left dinner and we
went to the house we were talking we
went back to the house and we were there
until about 11 30 12 o'clock
uh
we said i said i said chad's chas is a
man's man okay that's what i see he's a
man's man
i come from a lineage of man's man it's
different when you are around man's man
the language is different the swagger is
different the respect is different the
expectation is different
things that don't matter to the average
person is going to matter a little bit
more to the man's man there's certain
things you can't cross the line on
certain things with them there's certain
things that's respect
thoughts
on
you with movies movies have a lot of
power right john q was the first movie
where i sat there and i said man that
kid should have had a heart man what are
we going to do with this quarter million
dollars that cost to get that hard like
what do we do with health insurance
there's there's influence with movies
right
last 20 years men in movies are like you
know
presented as weak fragile pansies
softies you know
being pushed around you know they're
they're a joke they're a laughing stock
how much of this
direction we're going in the way we're
shaping and presenting how men are are
we losing the concept of man's man
because today masculinity is a little
bit frowned upon like if you're you're
too much of a man's man it's kind of
like well that's not respectful well
that's not this and you become almost
the target so how does a man's man today
survive in a era where it's frowned upon
to be a man's man
i you know what it's that's a good
question patrick
people you know women complain about
chivalry and i sometimes i would say
well you're the one who killed it you
know don't complain about it
you know i remember i was trying to
i i was on a i was on a plane and the
woman
she had her stuff there and yeah it was
kind of she was struggling to get it off
the top and i said excuse me i said i'll
get a feel honey i i just meant i said
honey yeah and she said excuse me
i could do it and i'm not honey
i said oh i'm i'm sorry you know and she
kind of yelled it like not yelled at it
but people hurt yeah yeah and i was just
oh okay i'm sorry and i was like wow
i was trying to help her yeah good luck
then i didn't mean anything by that i
wasn't saying hey honey i just said no
oh excuse me honey i'll get it for you
you know as being a man yeah and she
like jumped on my case you know i'm not
your honey and i could get it
and i was like whoa wow well you being
in hollywood what's your take on the me
too movement feminism
i'm curious to know if he goes deeper on
that are you going to go deeper on that
because you're a pretty deep guy because
i'm sitting there having a conversation
and i say hey ladies can we do this and
we're at a restaurant say hi ladies and
one the girl says don't call me a lady i
said
i'm sorry what can i call you right you
just can call me a woman i'm a woman i'm
not a lady i said so i stepped back i'm
like i'm trying to see why so can i ask
you just for my own curiosity he says if
i'm a lady you're a lord you're not a
lord i said wow
there's nothing you could say yes i mean
you got to walk away yeah i know i did i
walked when i had my food but the point
is you know like you you
you uh uh uh it's almost uh you're a
target today that's all i'm saying yeah
i feel bad for those people because it's
a lot of it is coming from like
internalized hatred and stuff that they
don't you know it's it's a way for them
i don't think it's internalized you
don't think so no i don't think this is
a way for them to feel powerful in ways
that they don't feel powerful and
they're
you know i'm just imagine having to go
through life and everything has to be
filtered through the lens of how can i
make this
about me how can i make this about this
offends me you you should have known
this way
no that's todd bro i'm sorry i can't buy
that i think that is taught there's we
spent an hour and 30 minutes so far in
this podcast talking about the value of
somebody teaching you good or bad
principles and then he said 100 is
parenting i says i don't know if it's
100 let's say it's 90 parenting let's
put the number on whatever ratios we
want to use
i think that is taught through a
generation and you think it's normal
it's very simple it's taught and i i'm
having a hard time with that because for
my kids you know what you know one of my
kids something happened was a bully and
they said yeah
in school this one school they were
going to in school daddy they're telling
us even if somebody hits you never hit
back so i said yeah really yeah i said
listen here's what we're going to do i'm
going to call your teacher so i called
the teacher and i went and met the
school i went and had everybody that
said so here's what i'm being told i
just want to manage the expectation
because we have to be on the same page
because you know as teachers and uh
parents we're on the same team we're
trying to raise good citizens right so
yeah of course yes fantastic i said so
this kid is bullying my son okay
he's being told to just come and tell
you guys so he's being taught to snitch
which is fine okay but i'm just trying
to understand this
i said is that what feedback is being
told yes now what is the limit of
limitation you guys have here for how
much he has to accept bullying until he
punches back no we don't tolerate that i
said okay so we have a challenge here so
what's that so because my kids come home
and my kids are instructed that if
somebody bullies you respectfully you
tell them to stop okay and you address
it and then if it happens continuously
you have to punch him in the face
that's a specific instruction somebody
may disagree with the sense that this is
not the right way to do right you have
to do in every possible way to avoid
conflict but you got to stand up
and then they're going back and forth
well that's not the right way of
parenting i said i'm sorry i'm not going
to raise little pansies yeah
here let me tell you why
let me tell you why
when i went
after my parents got a divorce and i
lived in germany and there was no father
figure
and it was me my sister and my mom and
they're both attractive yeah
the world is an ugly world if you're
going to be soft they're going to devour
you
so you want me to raise kids that are
going to be bullied the rest of their
life hail to the effing no it's not
going to happen right
so that's the part where i'm asking
because
you know like imagine if your son hangs
out with him for three months yeah what
do you think is going to happen
no honestly i want you actually thinking
but you got a kid he hangs out with
chess for three months what do you think
happens to your son
he comes smooth
forget about being smooth yeah he's
going to learn the right way to actually
learn values and principles of what it
is to be a man right that's the
challenge i'm having i don't know if you
have anything called so no i am so proud
of my son i have a son dante who's 25
years old
six two like you know me
dropped dead handsome built stud fud he
could fight
i i told him how to fight just like my
dad taught me how to fight since he's
three years old like a boxer
versus jake paul right here on
valuetainment my son is i'll when we get
off camera i'll show you some things my
son could fight and he could and and but
you know what i always told him i always
said to him dante when he was young i'm
teaching you how to fight so you don't
fight remember that
i know that my son is a stand-up
graduated berkeley
he'll he'll walk away but let me tell
you something but if you push it
he will he will put you out he will mma
you know the whole thing all you have to
do is build a reputation once yes you
have to you have to teach a person to
fight you have to if i have a son if i
had another son i would teach him and i
and my grandfather taught my father my
father taught me i thought my son and my
son will teach his kids not just a boy a
girl too no that's what's going to ask
on the other side of it you guys are
both fathers to daughters so if somebody
comes up something like somebody at
school made an unwanted advance on your
daughter and she came home dad how do i
handle it what are you what are you
telling her well i i wanted to go to
someone and tell them and see how they
handle it just like patrick did if they
handle it the right way and say hey
you did it once you never do it again
because if you do it you're going to get
expelled yeah then his boy doesn't have
to worry but if this boy keeps doing it
and they keep telling this kid you can't
do anything back no no no
i grew up where a guy was a bully yeah
you want to be a bully boom let's go for
it yeah you know what it stopped it was
over no more bullying fights in the
school yeah it only takes a couple times
the world
the world is an ugly place
people feed off you you gotta and if
they see weakness they keep it up
they keep it up i had a thing a year ago
i don't get into fights anymore i have
two i have two off-duty cops that travel
everywhere with me and they'll stop it
but this one guy i was sitting standing
at the bar and he came up with me goes
he goes yeah you were here three weeks
ago i saw you
you remember me and i did remember him
because i was with a table and he walked
over and said hey i love your movies and
i said thank you
and he pulls up a chair and sits down i
mean you don't do that and i said excuse
me
i'm i'm with a party here i i thank you
that you love my movies but i'm sorry
i'm with people and he got up and left
so then three weeks later he sees me he
comes he goes yeah you dissed me last w
a few weeks ago i said i what
he goes you diss me i go look i was with
a party and you came over i'm sorry you
know he goes yeah well i didn't like
that
and i could feel mike the guy who's with
me holding my arm my one of my
bodyguards
and he goes wait i go i told him just
wait a second i said look if i did do
something i apologize i'm very sorry i
didn't i don't think i did but if i did
i truly apologize
and he said yeah well you know what
that's not enough
and i says well then i don't know what
to tell you that and he was a big guy
you know and then he leans over to me at
the bar
and he says you know
i'm a [ __ ] tough guy says this to me
so now all of a sudden i went way back
in the street i went all of a sudden i
said okay i know what i'm dealing with
now i said that's good
i said because i'm a [ __ ] tough guy
too
so what do you want to do
and he went to me looked at me and went
come on i'm key anyway i'm just teasing
you hey man oh i really love your movie
i you know i said all right we're cool
man and he walked away
he pushed me to the point where i had to
show him
hey man
you want to play make him move let's go
until i did that
he would have kept going yeah how long
ago was this by the way about a year ago
a year ago a year ago no i thought he
said three weeks ago you brought up uh
you you reminded me of a story no
um respect chess no no it but it's not
it's just come on guys yeah yeah that's
enough
do everything you can to avoid the fight
you know in the school you hope to have
a law and order where it doesn't even
come to you some schools do great but
the kids are going to the school right
now we had an incident they didn't even
make it up to me that i need i didn't
need to go to school they handled it
themselves
see i i was i was taught wrong
like you guys are right but i was taught
wrong but uh i'll never forget i was in
first grade and uh there was a kid named
matt and he was uh he was kind of a
bully my mom was a the lunch uh what
would it call like they come and they
like lunch lady well lunch lady but
they're like uh
cafeteria worker no they like chaperone
during recess or whatever like whatever
so this the guy calls him
he my mom tells the kid to stop doing
what he's doing he was like pinching a
girl or something like that i was like
matthew stop and he goes shut up [ __ ]
to my mom and i was like oh
like you don't do that to my mom like my
mom's a warrior woman dude like oh
and then
i come home my dad's never home he
worked in the city he was home at eight
o'clock at night when i come home my
dad's waiting for me at home and goes
hey did matt call your mom a [ __ ] today
at school i was like yeah i can't
believe he goes what'd you do i was like
nothing he was like okay this is what
you're gonna do as soon as you get off
the bus tomorrow you're gonna walk up
the mat you're going to punch him in the
face you're going to keep punching him
until you can't punch anymore
and i'm like i don't think i'm allowed
to do that he goes you're allowed to do
that go do that so first thing i get off
the bus in the morning i go i punch this
kid i beat the living crap at him i'm
crying while i'm on top of him the whole
time i obviously get dragged to the
principal's office was like what the
heck was that about i was like i called
my mom a [ __ ]
so my dad's there obviously call that
work he's there he goes gerard i am so
disappointed in you this is not how i'm
like sitting there like shocked like
what the what just happened here he
comes out and he goes hey free day off
and he pounds me we go get ice cream he
takes me to a yankee game that night
he was like look man
sometimes there's there's
there's a part of that that's not
your dad didn't do you wrong dude
there's a part of that that's kind of
like
you know he he taught you to protect
your mom and your two sisters you got
two sisters right there was a better way
to go about it i'm not saying listen the
one thing about parenting that sucks is
there's no freaking manual you know you
you can say the bible yes yes there's a
but there's not a manual that says
if this thing happens what do you do go
to page 396 to see seven steps on how to
handle this you kind of gotta freaking
go off the cuff
he was so legitimately mad at me that he
had to teach me that lessons like you
didn't think
chaz the guy just uh jack hasso
uh posted a question here about lilo
brancato i've heard you talk about him
before when he got in trouble himself
because he was a star coming up at a
young age and he didn't know how to
handle a good-looking guy he does a
movie like bronx tale he's partying he's
everywhere women are all over him what
happened to him he's out right now i
know he's out but what happened with his
story what happened was he you know he
he was 16 years old i mean it was too
much too soon you know
he believed all the the press reviews
and everything and
he just acted terrible and got involved
with drugs he became a junkie and
and it was funny because as the years
were going on i used to say to him i
said lilo you were in the quintessential
movie about not wasting your life and
that's wasted talent and it's exactly
what you're doing wow
i said do you realize that you're you're
living the movie yeah what was his
response no no i'm gonna be cool i'm
gonna be cool yeah three weeks before it
happened he came to my house because he
wanted me to do a movie write a movie
about this guy and he was stoned i said
lilo it's gonna happen sooner or later
three weeks later a big report on the
news that a cop died was shot he was
with the guy and that was it are you
still in touch with him no i don't speak
to him anymore
i tried for ten years to talk to him and
now
i look he's a talented kid he could have
been a big star
but my friendship is over with him but i
wish him well i i hear he straightened
his life out i think that's great i hear
he helps kids i think that's great and i
wish him well how did you look at him as
a son at some point no no no chaz how
how often does that happen where
do you see like not being able to manage
the limelight is there what comes with
the limelight i mean when you get the
lime can okay so for example you you're
doing broad you're doing a theater right
you're doing all this and great
how many people are in audience by the
way five hundred thousand ten thousand
five thousand uh the most twenty five
three thousand let's say twenty five
hundred to three thousand people there's
a big difference between twenty five
hundred to three thousand to fifty
million people watching movie right it's
a big big difference
what happened the moment bronx still
became a hit and you're nominated for
the academy what happens to your life
what happened overnight it was amazing
i was totally
i was totally unknown i was an actor but
i was totally unknown the next minute
i remember we're flying
we're flying to paris
uh i'm on a private jet with bob and
we're flying to paris and
he's sleeping in one bed and i'm
sleeping the other and i wake up
and i just looked at him
sleeping there
i look out the window you know blackness
and
i went wow
here i was like
months before
and now i'm on a private jet with bobby
nero you know
and i got up i'll never forget it and
there was a guy just sitting there
reading he was like the butler you know
and i said do you have any i was a
little hungry i said do you have any
like um you know finger food or
something like it i'm a little hungry
you know i was never on a private jet
before
and he said well what would you like
that you want some pancakes or french
toast or something
and i was like oh
uh pancakes french toast
[Laughter]
opens up the table he puts the white
table yeah he puts a rose there on a
thing and like you know such this
beautiful table up i'm sitting there and
he's cooking and he's making me pancakes
and i'm eating
scrambled eggs and i'm looking i'm
eating and i look over and bob is
sleeping and i go
all right chas i go but you belong here
but i said that to myself i said
you belong here it's okay but that was
one that was a moment it's funny you
brought that up patrick that was one of
the first moments that i was like yeah
wow and then we got off the plane in
france
in paris and there was this giant giant
wall
with bob's face and my face looking at
each other it's that posting yeah and i
was like wow pull up the poster by the
way that's one of the sickest posters
when you interviewed mike tyson yeah and
he was the world champion and and you
asked the question of just giving me
sort of vibes like this you said
when did you know you would be the
champion and he says uh
what was his response when he was 14
years old you sometimes you have to be
the child
you have to believe you're a champion
before you become a champion there's a
lot of similarities there is that
basically how you knew you were there
there's a saying
you have to go there in the mine
before you can go there physically
you know uh and it's like when people
train like navy seals why they train so
much
and when they get into the [ __ ]
they're there already because they
trained it yeah they're there so you
have to go there in your mind you know
so i always already pitched myself
working with great people and what age i
saw that mindset started
god
i want to be an actor with 10 probably
in my you know 11 12 13. so when you're
38 and that 250 000
check comes you're thinking no i'm i'm
going to hold out the only person the
only person that i ever got star struck
and i worked with all of them the
biggest stars
the only person i could never get over
who he was is frank sinatra wow
only one you've been on set with sophia
vergara not star struck even a little
bit
she's a beautiful person
what was the interaction with them
it's not sofia loren yeah it's a very
big exactly
every time i was with him
i would just kind of just put my head
down and go frank's so natural
i couldn't get over
i just couldn't get over who he was he
was the only one because he was like to
me
you know i it's the famous it's a famous
story i told it on a tonight show and
it's in a book
it's and that's when we were sitting
there we everybody went inside and i was
at a barbecue at frank's house this one
time i'm sitting there with him and also
he goes uh
hey charles you know bronstead's one of
my favorite movies i said oh thanks
frank he goes it was a great movie i
said thanks frank he goes you know why
it was a great movie and i'm like why
frank he goes because i didn't [ __ ]
fall asleep
that's what he said she went back so
then he goes to me he goes uh
and we're talking and we're having a
great time and he's got he's got a
martini with two olives in it
did i ever tell you this no so he takes
the he takes the two pick out
with the two arms and at the end and and
he goes chest come on share my owl and i
said what he goes
go ahead take dialogue share it with me
so i didn't know what he was doing so i
took the olive off the toothpick and he
goes you ready i go yeah and we pop the
arms and i'm out and he hugs me goes i
love you man you're a good kid you know
you're always welcome to come around
frank sinatra
wow whatever so i said i said well
thanks frank he goes come on let's go
inside everybody's eating waiting for us
i said all right we walk inside and
everybody's you know serving they're
serving a
smorgasbord of food
and all of a sudden i go up to uh
don rickles
oh my god don rickles was there with oh
my god steven edie gourmet don rickles
deniro was there and a couple other i
think sean connery was there too so i
walk over there and i and i go his name
just come out of your mind yeah and i go
over there and i go hey i go what's with
this
with this this olive thing frank just
never did that before to me what's that
about
right and i hear a voice behind me go
frank sharon with you
and i turn around and it's gregory
gregory peck the great actor
they were best friends him and frank
so i said yeah what's this this olive
thing
he goes that's a sign of great
friendship jazz the rat pack would share
their olives together after they drank
martinis and it's a sign of being a bond
yeah
he goes if frank did that with you
welcome to the club that's incredible i
was blown away that's incredible i was
blown away what an experience how did
you handle limelight because sometimes
when you go from overnight
and now the world knows who you are
that's a that's dramatic that's not a
little bit you know how do you how do
you how do you manage that i just
managed it you know i just managed i'm
like was it hard sometimes yes
sometimes you just gotta go you know
okay i'm cool
you know i'll be all right you know you
just gotta
you know
i don't forget i was 38 40. so i wasn't
a kid
anybody who makes it under the age of 20
or 30 is is insane yeah so i was already
seasoned
but even me even at my age it was still
like you know all of a sudden you you
have you know all these people want
something from you you know i was always
you know i i i always had girls so it
wasn't like i never had girls before
you know but it's just this constant
level of women
and and money and people and
and what which sounds horrible it would
save me was no but believe me what saved
me was i i had a beautiful i met a
beautiful girl
my wife and i got married right around
the time bronxdale was coming out
so people go my friends are going what
are you crazy you're getting married
are you out of your mind yeah you know
and i said look man i've had a lot of
pretty girls i've got i grew up i've had
a lot of women in my life you know do
you believe in the in the three great
women in your life no question no
question i believe that you know i mean
that's one of my things that's how i
wrote it in look think about it how many
times have you felt think about it how
will you know you guys are younger
how many times have you fell in love in
your life think about it once
twice twice maybe twice that's it three
times three three times is like forget
it you only get three atoms once a week
every week
the panthers
you got to listen to my podcast because
i talk about this whole thing about that
with sandy blue eyes come on no no they
come around every 10 years like great
fighters
exactly but here's the thing about that
is yes could you have all the women in
the world but some of the biggest ladies
men in the world are very lonely yeah
you know very lonely you know happiness
is is marriage and meaning of family and
being you know look is it hard yeah but
that's the way life is
chaz what is the modern day
door test
in the movie you said
you know what you're going to do the
test she orders the uber okay no no and
she goes oh
and they go oh the morning
as soon as the door closes she has to
get the automatic thing on her side and
hit it a few times so the button goes
quickly quickly
now in the old days you have to lift it
up but now
but now with social media and dating
apps i gotta tell as as comedians you
know don rickles is is as good as it
gets and you talked about frank sinatra
one of the funniest stories i ever heard
don rick was talking about marriage he's
like he was explaining i believe it was
the carson how he fell in love with his
wife and i guess he was married for a
very long time so he finds this girl
he's madly in love with and he's begging
frank sinatra he's like frank i got this
girl it's a great story
i want to make it with this girlfriend i
told you this story
yes he's like you got you got to coach
you want to take the story wow okay sure
i mean yeah it's fine he says uh frank
you're the biggest star in the world
right uh do me a favor i'm going to have
dinner with this girl
and just come by and say hi and he's
like i'm not going to come by
i'm not gonna do this guy come on frank
please come on have a little response i
wanna i wanna help me help me out here
[ __ ] frank sinatra don listen i'm not
coming over to your table it's like just
leave me alone don please
all right okay don rickles i'll come so
frank she's 10 o'clock don't be late 10
o'clock exactly he sets it up i'll be
with the girl
and it's all right frank sinatra i'll
come over to your table and say hi and
frank sinatra comes over to don reckles
tables hey don how you doing don goes
frank i'm having dinner here i have a
little respect
what are you doing interrupting my
dinner that's him and that's uh it's
like
he's set frank sinatra
you're kidding me no it's like the best
downward experience oh i can tell you i
can tell you rickles stories he says he
goes you know frank's three wives were
all named joanne
wow i i didn't know that he goes you
know frank he goes you know my frank
picks all he's doing he goes chief
bastard doesn't want to change the bed
tower
jay carson jake
so he goes let me tell you something oh
i could i could go once this is rickles
this is rickles he was one of a kind by
the way the rickles goes to me goes you
know rick will save my life
you know sinatra says this no rickles is
saying sinatra say
save my life rickles is telling me i
said really he goes yeah i said i said
donna you seriously
saved my life
i said what happened he goes 1967 front
of caesar's palace three guys stopped
beating me over the hell with baseball
bats
beating the [ __ ] out of me frank walks
out and says that's enough
[Laughter]
jeez louise man and you played vegas for
you were in vegas for how long oh eight
seven eight years i was in vegas
he goes to me he goes to me he goes is
frank big his friend you frank slash
frank's over there goes this frank big
frank's so big look at him he wears a
cross with nobody on it
you know like you know nobody i mean
i mean rickles is first day i met him
first time i met don rickles was at
sinatra's house the first time i met him
i walk in and dinero introduced me
because he goes this is don rickles and
danielle looks at me right from
everybody everybody's standing he goes
hey josh palmitary where the [ __ ] would
you be without robert de niro
do you have like a mountain rush
first thing do you have a mount rushmore
of people that are the icons like
obviously frank sinatra's price
is there anybody out like is daenerys on
that list
yeah who's on chaz commentaries not rush
yeah you know of course de niro you know
the greatest act of our generation you
know who knows maybe of all time i don't
know but uh dinero and you what a great
artist but
the italians yeah
no i mean yeah
i would say yeah they happen to be
italian
you know last
so i can't you know i was supposed to go
and to his house i'll never forget it
sean penn asked me says hey while
meeting with with marlon tonight you
want to come and i was getting on a
plane i should have just turned around
and walked off the damn thing but i
didn't i said no i'm getting on a plane
yeah sean penn asked you to go to marlon
brando's house the plane can wait you
know i should have did it but let me let
me you should have done a couple things
i should have yes i'm gonna ask two
current events i'm gonna ask two current
event questions and see what you think
about okay scarlett johansson is suing
disney okay what it means to hollywood's
future right scarlett johansson and
disney are in brooklyn the legal battle
you know it's not looking pretty you
know because the movie went straight and
you know johansen also allegedly that
disney's decision to release the film
and the current environment robbed her
50 million dollars in box office
similar thing is happening also with the
uh woody caller with the saints of
newark yeah
many saints of newark which is like hey
why are we not going into movies and all
this stuff what what is changing about
hollywood right now especially since
covid
because a lot of guys are like we're not
going to go into theater we're just
going straight to stream and service
yeah what's changed with hollywood well
it's faster you know
instead of just showing it so the movie
runs well think about it how many people
are going to see it in the movie you got
to show it what
3 000 screens and
it's first of all that movie wasn't like
that you know you don't know
how many people could see it but if you
see it online
and put it out there for the world to
see
it's a big difference but now but it but
the salary has to act accordingly to
that and they didn't catch up you know
we're not caught up with the media yet
you know we're not
the big actors have to work it out i you
know you get not many people get 20
million dollars to do a movie you know
there's only a few leo does it and
denzel they get 20 million but if
they're going to say you're going to
stream it to the world now you're going
to say all right give me my 20 million
but then i want a piece of that whole
stream
they haven't worked that out yet
got it so that's still being worked i
mean they'll figure it out don't figure
it out but that hasn't been worked out
yet yeah interesting who's winning more
right now the studio or the actor
oh the right now the actors okay the
actors because
look
here's the deal
years ago when i growing up you had
channel two channel four channel seven
you know
all of a sudden now it's a big
difference now now they're shaking in
their boots because look you have your
own podcast you get two million people
three million people i have my own
podcast you have subscribers you have a
channel you actually have a channel
you know patrick has a channel you guys
have a channel you know pd podcast i
said a channel how many subscribers
millions
how many you know how many people see
the tonight show a million
maybe million and a half see it every
night
you know that's all so you're out you're
out doing them so they're shaking in
their boots saying hey wait a minute
what's going on here
right a lot of these guys a lot of these
stand-up comics they don't want to go on
uh
hbo netflix you know what they do they
put their own channel up louis c.k did
it put his own channel up
signed up money boom he gets all the
money well back in the day the biggest
honor ever were to go on carson it was
carson carson but then maybe turn in the
letter letterman and now
so it's changed it's crazy it's gone
it's gone towards the artist now if the
artist is smart he's a good entrepreneur
is this a good or bad thing i think it's
a good thing okay that's an evolution i
mean i think it's an evolution yeah i
think you bring up a good point whether
it's a good or bad thing it's a thing
now it's not it's not going away it's
not going away yeah i mean ricky gerray
said listen all this stuff with movies
we may as well just give all the
trophies to netflix because they're
taking help they're taking everything
right they yeah one by one by one uh uh
uh mob movies when's the last time we
had a good mob movie like something
where you can say like a
bronx tale like a good fella stop
haven't had one in a while yeah why do
you think it's been a while well because
it's hard to make a good one that it's
hard to make one that hasn't been done
before that departed with leo and uh
yeah but it's hard to make those yeah
excuse me but it's hard to make those
movies now it's hard people go i want to
see another movie
unless it's really great then they want
to see it
but i think i think you have to push the
envelope and try new different things
you know
i really believe that that's why i like
independent movies
i've always liked independent movies
more people can make movies now for less
less money yeah
we we have a guy in house zach parker uh
produced an independent film actually
wanted uh sundance who's zach parker
i know if he watches this he's gonna
understand my jokes tell the people
where they can see um your show yeah the
one man show everything i'm still doing
the one-man show with all these years i
do it if they go to transparentary.net
that is my website you can buy tickets
you could see i'm booked for this this
year and next year
and i know you guys are going to come
and see me one day
do you have any final questions from him
on ladies any specific tips because you
know here's a man he tells us he wants
to have a family one day
he tells us how old are you now i'm 40.
oh you're 40 well you look a lot younger
thanks chaz yeah i appreciate that you
didn't make a change you just made his
money you made his money
yeah well here's how you got to look at
it here's what i tell people
you know if you had a job and you made a
lot of money each week you made five
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars a
week it's a nice salary but that ten
thousand dollars a week that whole week
you blew it
you just spent it all well let's just
say what i do oh let's just save that
money but let's just say you blew it you
blew it but think of though think of the
money as its emotions
you blew the five thousand each week
boom you blew it alone boom boom blew it
blew it and at the end of your lifetime
you got no money in the bank you got
nothing but you but now think of it as
emotions if you meet a great woman and
each week you're putting that money in
the back what is that money it's
memories your children your wife your
family and at the end of your lifetime
you're going to have all these riches of
a moment you're not gonna it's not that
one guy's gonna have no money in the
bank emotionally and the other guy's
gonna be rich emotionally
so when you pass on
in which we all will when you're on your
deathbed and you you have a wife and
great kids
that you go hey man it's cool
as opposed to just living for pleasure
and not happiness
is it hard yes it is do i still struggle
with it yes i do we're just works in
progress that's all we are but it's the
ones who have the discipline
are the ones who in the end are happy
true you're so cool jazz you're gonna
tell him yeah also you know i gotta tell
you too man like watching watching the
way you like your your relationship in
particular the way you and jenna are man
it's changed my view
on marriage really and i told you guys
last night this is not a bit this is me
being for real i want to be a father i
just i really have no interest in being
a husband at this point in life i just
and i know that the key word right there
is at this point in life but the more
you don't have to do it yeah you know
what i i've never really seen a
partnership the way i see a partnership
with you guys and i see it's like the
value in that attracts me you know your
value when having someone who has your
back as you get older attracts you know
because you know you never really needed
that like emotional
um
you know that i never needed that
sanctuary i always had my friends i
always had my boys now as i'm getting
older man those guys are coming off
they're starting their own families and
you do feel a little bit more alone and
you can definitely see the value of it
you know it's in the dna look here's
here's the deal the problem is men are
were born to be procreate yeah
and women
men are attracted to aesthetics
beautiful you see people with the eyes
with the eyes
women are attracted to power
and that comes from the cave man you
know they they took the biggest cavemen
the most handsome came in because they
wanted to be with him because they knew
they were going to eat yeah i'm with
this guy i'm eating yeah this guy's
going to make sure
he's consistently the same
and he wanted to be with the most
beautiful girl i want to have kids yeah
and that's in our dna that's printed
there
so every once you're married but you see
a beautiful woman you oh man jesus go oh
boy
it takes discipline ma'am it takes
discipline and women
you know why'd you say i see so many
people women with ugly guys but they're
not thinking about it they're thinking
of the the power hey i'm with this for
the money and the money well the money
yeah well that's part of the problem
so but that's in our dna and we have to
fight that all the time both of us both
races women men have to fight all of
that both the time i'm with my husband
yeah well he's a bus driver but gee this
other guy's a lawyer ma'am i don't know
you know it's always everybody goes
through this man i think what he's
trying to tell you is find a russian
woman
i won't talk about that
we won't go there but we won't go there
let me tell you if you guys thought this
podcast was fun which it clearly was
dinner last night last night everybody's
watching saying why the hell are they
laughing as hard as they're laughing
anyways thank you for all the stuff if
you enjoyed the podcast go click on
chaz's podcast below we got the link
below uh cha kai put it in the comment
section as well as the
chat live chat section if you can uh go
subscribe to his channel he's got a
bunch of great stories to share
uh with you a ton of it and um
he explains clips he brings different
people there
but if you haven't yet subscribed to his
channel please do so more short clips
will be coming out on our valuetainment
short clip channel uh having said that
chaz thank you so much for coming out
and being a guest man this was great
really great really great yes have a
good one take care all right
you